you know there's been this news article
about men that think that they could
beat Serena Williams in tennis right
that they think that they could actually
score a point on her
um and it's just not the case she is
stronger than that what's your
experience Ben
male female both Serena and Venus lost
to the 203rd ranked male tennis player
which they're phenoms for women my
experience my husband he swam at
University of Kentucky as well in terms
of accolades and in terms of national
ranking I was a much better swimmer than
him he could kick my butt any day of the
week without trying it took us about 10
seconds to find this video which we've
shown you before here's Serena Williams
on females versus males in tennis for me
tennis and men's tennis and women's sins
are completely almost two separate
Sports so I'm like if I were to play
Andy Murray I would lose 6060 and five
to six minutes maybe 10 minutes because
no it's true it's